I feel like this is a method for 100%
that's why she's here she's here for me
to take the W R have you played on this
before I have but I'm not really good at
it all right well let's just play ball
wait that's baseball oh oh oh my god
welcome ladies okay here we go
wow you are adorable
you guys ready to play yeah I'm super
distracted um who is what do you think
heads or tails heads heads yeah okay you
choose you choose I think tails it was
it was heads it was 100% heads so you
pig who serves first I'll let amanecer
okay mando sexy oh wait I'm like all
right love all first question is how did
you get started with beauty and makeup
and all that good stuff I used to do it
on myself
15-love used to do it on yourself yeah I
used to dance
I had to do stage makeup on myself since
I was five but I started when I was 17
and I would do everyone's makeup for $45
in my bedroom yep
that's so cool you're a little hustler I
know right making that money honey from
an early age love it
you still haven't done my makeup that
was out second serve going a barks are
you sure yep it's all right I don't know
maybe you're right pretty sure was then
though I'm pretty sure by now was out
right totally out it's like a turn to
try to hit inside the boxes second serve
second serve yep
you still haven't done my makeup yet one
day we're gonna glam one day you're
gonna make come on man 30-love gonna be
my friend any more afternoon who's your
favorite client
that's hard oh it was out that one was
out oh that was out yep okay so are we
done yeah
my favorite class I feel like my muse
right now has to be Chloe Chloe I just
really like it
this is not cool thank you very for that
what do you love but you set all this up
right for you to play everyone uh-huh
it's like you look good playing all my
friends and how do I talk and hit it at
the same time you just got your your
birthday recently too huh yeah and you
went to today whoa Wow
fifteen so can you speak Spanish
no no habla español un poco de dah
can you speak any other languages
I can speak Armenian speak to me in
Armenian hide in closed out second serve
what did you say I said do you speak
Armenian hide and wholesomeness if I say
hi I am yes you say IO IO highest do I
owe
that's all I need to know yeah right
here oh the second serve how often so
your whole family is from Armenia yes
how often do you go there Oh Ferdy
that was good right yeah tried I put my
heart into it so do they all live in the
u.s. now or they still live there um my
mom said lives in Armenia and Russia
yeah my dad said lives here oh cool but
I was born in Armenia when it was a
communist oh do what I think I'm winning
numbers but Oh
what's one mistake that I always make
with my makeup that you notice advantage
Amanda I can't like you don't need
make-up you're so beautiful oh you are
thank you but you can be honest the
lashes yeah yeah so what do I need to do
you just need to stick it on oh it's the
offering I'm nothing like stick it on
fully oh I kind of dangles sometimes
it's sometimes but I feel like
everyone's does oh it's out
those are some parties for me to figure
out I'll show y'all haven't we need to
do it the Touareg I'll show you the
easiest way to go please a little bit
yeah what's it like the trick to it you
have to place it in the center but like
when it's like tacky not when it's wet
oh and then you have to do the outer
edge yeah and then the inner corner I
don't do that yeah noted ah Amanda but I
have a pretty good background yeah we do
yeah you're actually doing great I got
hitting it like this I feel like I'm
hitting it like this my backhand sucks
my everything sucks
no I have a mean backhand that's good
all no not not to hit it that way now so
how did you start doing the makeup for
the Kardashians it's been I could say
like four years and I feel like
it's changed my life in many ways yeah
like mindset so wait I from here
I saw yes from here over there yeah very
good love baby don't know what you're
talking about
oh you got a puppy point you keep
sticking that tongue out those guys keep
looking cute are you talking to me so
how did it change your life I feel like
their perspective and like business yeah
oh oh very nice
third got me on the back end like in
business and just oh come on now that
was outside out out out
wait that was out out what do you love
hey have you had your eyes checked
recently
what do you love I'm like where did it
go at 8:15 so what are they like what's
one of the best things that you've
learned about business from them you
have to be so persistent never take no
for an answer
wake up super early grind till asleep
and Wilmer don't ever yeah you know
that's true and they all work so hard so
seeing that you want to work hard too
people don't know that
Oh 40 30 that's true people think it's
so easy for them a lot of the time I
agree but I feel like people don't see
how much they work yeah from like their
eyes opening eyes closing it's all work
and they do so much charity I feel like
it's kind of corny to like display what
you're doing
mm-hmm and they don't yeah I feel like
they definitely deserve a lot more
credit in that Avenue I hear through
like outside people of the like the
stuff that they're working on and the
stuff that they do I love what can do
with like plastic water yeah I mean
plastic bottles for the water in the
ocean like it's just so much stuff like
they promote a tiny bit just to create
awareness but like not to game be
totally like today they're doing a poker
tournament yeah for City of Hope oh I
know
did you hear about them no oh I need to
learn how to play poker
I need a lot of flavor kind of bro are
you a good poker player
Oh advantage Bruce I think you Hannes
and you should get married like next
week what what do you mean too soon no I
really I have to move into the house we
have to get a dog there's this process
like hey but you shouldn't be that's
like immediate with it should be like oh
yeah we have time this is true life is
way too short to plan why do you think
your Honus is good for me what's your
answer that's what happens with that
point huh what's your answer
what I why do I think Johanna said he's
a good guy look at him taking care white
Irish that's a game point right there
what yeah that was it like where are you
gonna find a guy like this I feel like
you guys have a side deal going this
whole game you compliment Johannes
Johannes gets to play with your dog I
think you're getting very paranoid up
this boy make it so maybe the sun's
getting to you think it's a lot of Sun
yeah [ __ ]
no see I know what we're doing it's got
one huh
one one yeah we both won one round camp
that was a really good answer
he's a good guy what's your favorite
trend so far of 2018
my favorite trend yeah okay goes back
here that was out that one was out
love-15 okay suck it easy how does it
taste
come on that was really out yeah oh I
serve yeah
she's all like yes messing me up did you
undermine me boo boo well I didn't
you're adding new rules to tennis here
so what's your favorite trend I feel
like my trend right now that I do shoe
is how everyone's being a little bit
more raw Wow love-30 well is that like
how everyone's just being unfiltered on
social media I do love that oh it's out
out yeah I was out anyways otherwise
she's gonna play it love-40 I think
you're hypnotized hey you are it you're
just full of distractions and I like
them I'm not mad at they distract second
serve ha who's your favorite person to
follow on social media you ahh
I like it why
gamer's which side which side am i
throwing over here cap whoo
why me because they're funny asphalt Hey
love-15
and I like to laugh that's true you do
yeah let's tell the story of how we met
we met in Miami you are with Jonathan
Jonathan yeah and at something crap a
Joe's out
love-30 I think it's the Windham catch
and then we just party to Miami from
Yahoo I just love at first sight with us
it was and it still is what did I teach
you to do oh you taught me how to cover
up at the restaurant aside from that ah
named Haroon
I have a question who was serving Cheers
yeah why did you serve right now oh okay
you sir Jhon acquaintance huh besides
that
what did you teach me I don't know tell
me regarding what Oh
love-40 what did you teach me oh my god
yes you taught me how to make it rain
yup we went to Club eleven and there's
like a unique nightlife experience
yeah and there's like you know a certain
way to throw things yes it's like a
technique yeah yes you're teaching me
how to make a master before serving
yeah you sir yeah and honestly I needed
that because game Amanda last one ladies
here we go I'm serving or you're serving
I'm serving okay yeah that was a
much-needed thing to know though cuz
I've embarrassed myself so many times I
mean I don't really go to strip clubs
often no when you go you're like I'm
King I walk in there I'm just making it
rain on everybody I'm gonna get I should
have got you a gun oh that sprays out
confession oh my gift to you I'm dead do
you have one already I bet you as I do
but you could never have all come
15-love
you can never have enough of those
that's true I like to hold like I'm
gonna learn how to do it with my toes
too one yeah that'll be my birthday gift
to you is another gun you got me a
birthday gift which was hair perfume and
I love it you're gonna love that you're
gonna this is see like he's gonna really
like me and I'm gonna really like yeah
you're already point yeah
puppy points or whatever you want to
call it I hate that backhand
Oh 30-love I did not wear the
appropriate attire for this game we got
boobs flying everywhere you look good
though thanks babe if you're gonna lose
you might as well look good
40-love how many points does she have on
me it's one more if she gets one more
it's over okay how many do I need to win
her five points I'll lose and grace
there's still a chance Alya come down go
you can serve come on okay come on
imagine I just know yeah come come here
yeah yeah yeah she's in love with you
honest she is that one's out second
serve what we're just still playing and
I guess forty fifteen all
congratulations I'm sorry you lost but
that yeah and I'm sorry I know you lost
so you lost the doctor Eliab I and I
actually have a loaves prize for you
because you lost and you were such a
good sport you and you I was gonna lose
that's why you asked me to play tennis
yeah I did
they got you a very special gift what is
it
let's head out here so I'm about to face
me - I'm actually really tired I need
like a a juice or something since you
did such a good job of plane I got you I
know make up sure thing some new
foundation for you thank you for you and
a shower cap thank you guys so much for
watching
what geez hot Hollywood thank you guys
for watching make sure you like
subscribe turn on the notifications
check out her Rouge check out her
puppies page - I love her so much and I
actually haven't seen you in forever so
this is fun and let me know in the
comments you guys who you want to see me
play next I don't know why that's such a
hard line for me but it is love you see
you guys later
mwah good job color hey that's not they
sent me so much foundation and that's
the one I couldn't use that is now yours
to use as contour it's a compliment
really
because I wish I could be that tan
[Music]